three years ago i was
in icu and i was clinically
dead and this voice's
beautiful voice came to me
and he said i want you to go back
and learn about islam
i was clinically dead
and he sent me back and told me
to learn about islam
you know i never knew about islam
you know muslims
i thought they were a bunch of
terrorists
i got a hold of fehel who called
joseph and he came to my room
and i said the words and i became muslim
at that point it made me feel so
wonderful it's like the weight of the
world
went out on me
and i've never felt so
good after i said the words
to be muslim and being a good
muslim i don't eat pork anymore
i don't drink alcohol
i'm in peace my family members are
all christians and i don't
get into religion with them because i
can't convert
them you know but i do
pray to allah to help them
they told me that i was crazy
and they said to me
how can you become muslim
you know they thought muslims are
terrorists you know and
i get it from my family you know
jesus is the one
and only god yeah
well i think jesus was a good prophet
but all of the one and true only god
islam is the one and only way to go
i live brothers and sisters and when he
wants
me to go to jail
allah will call for me
and i will die in peace
because i know i'm muslim
you know people make fun of me i don't
care because i know what's in my heart
and that is islam
well that's my story brothers and
sisters
[Music]
brothers and sisters i
tell you there's an organization
out there uplift
dala is the greatest organization
run by yourself and
other muslims
if it wasn't for a blip dolla
i would be probably still a christian
[Music]
and as i've let dolla
help me convert
and i've been muslim for three years
now actually i'm going on the fourth
year
brothers and sisters please
donate anything 50 cents a dollar
a hundred dollars to uplift
the life and thank you brothers and
sisters for
listening to my story
[Music]